[Music]
let me share with you something that I
found particularly weird when I was a
student first learning calculus let's
say that you have a circle with radius
five centered at the origin of the XY
plane this is something defined with the
equation x squared plus y squared equals
5 squared that is all of the points on
the circle are a distance 5 from the
origin as encapsulated by the
Pythagorean theorem where the sum of the
squares of the two legs on this triangle
equal the square of the hypotenuse 5
squared and suppose that you want to
find the slope of a tangent line to the
circle maybe at the point XY equals 3/4
now if you're savvy with geometry you
might already know that this tangent
line is perpendicular to the radius
touching it at that point but let's say
you don't already know that or maybe you
want a technique that generalizes to
curves other than just circles as with
other problems about the slopes of
tangent lines to curves the key thought
here is to zoom in close enough that the
curve basically looks just like its own
tangent line and then ask about a tiny
step along that curve the Y component of
that little step is what you might call
dy and the X component is a little D X
so the slope that we want is the rise
over run dy / DX but unlike other
tangent slope problems in calculus this
curve is not the graph of a function so
we can't just take a simple derivative
asking about the size of some tiny nudge
to the output of a function caused by
some tiny nudge to the input X is not an
input and Y is not an output they're
both just interdependent values related
by some equation this is what's called
an implicit curve it's just the set of
all points X Y that satisfies some
property written in terms of the two
variables x and y the procedure for how
you actually find dy/dx for curves like
this is the thing that I found very
weird is a calculus student you take the
derivative
of both sides like this for x-squared
you write two x times DX
and similarly y squared becomes two y
times dy and then the derivative of that
constant v squared on the right is just
zero now you can see where this feels a
little strange right what does it mean
to take the derivative of an expression
that has multiple variables in it and
why is it that we're tacking on the
little dy and the little DX in this way
but if you just blindly move forward
with what you get you can rearrange this
equation and find an expression for dy
divided by DX which in this case comes
out to be negative x divided by y so at
the point with coordinates XY equals 3/4
that slope would be negative 3/4
evidently this strange process is called
implicit differentiation and don't worry
I have an explanation for how you can
interpret taking a derivative of an
expression with two variables like this
but first I want to set aside this
particular problem and show how it's
connected to a different type of
calculus problem something called a
related rates problem imagine a 5 meter
long ladder held up against a wall where
the top of the ladder starts 4 meters
above the ground which by the
Pythagorean theorem means that that
bottom is 3 meters away from the wall
and let's say it's slipping down in such
a way that the top of the ladder is
dropping at a rate of 1 meter per second
the question is in that initial moment
what's the rate at which the bottom of
the ladder is moving away from the wall
it's interesting right that distance
from the bottom of the ladder to the
wall is 100% determined by the distance
from the top of the ladder to the floor
so we should have enough information to
figure out how the rates of change for
each of those values actually depend on
each other but it might not be entirely
clear how exactly you relate those two
first things first it's always nice to
give names to the quantities that we
care about so let's label that distance
from the top of the ladder to the ground
Y of T written as a function of
because it's changing likewise label the
distance between the bottom of the
ladder and the wall X of T the key
equation that relates these terms is the
Pythagorean theorem X of T squared plus
y of T squared equals 5 squared what
makes that a powerful equation to use is
that it's true at all points of time
now one way that you could solve this
would be to isolate X of T and then you
figure out what Y of T has to be based
on that one meter per second drop rate
and you could take the derivative of the
resulting function DX DT the rate at
which X is changing with respect to time
and that's fine
it involves a couple layers of using the
chain rule and it'll definitely work for
you but I want to show a different way
that you can think about the same
problem this left-hand side of the
equation is a function of time right it
just so happens to equal a constant
meaning the value evidently doesn't
change while time passes but it's still
written as an expression dependent on
time which means we can manipulate it
like any other function that has T as an
input in particular we can take a
derivative of this left-hand side which
is a way of saying if I let a little bit
of time pass some small DT which causes
Y to slightly decrease an X to slightly
increase how much does this expression
change on the one hand we know that that
derivative should be 0 since the
expression is a constant and constants
don't care about your tiny nudges in
time they just remain unchanged but on
the other hand what do you get when you
compute this derivative well the
derivative of X of T squared is 2 times
X of T times the derivative of X that's
the chain rule that I talked about last
video 2x DX
represents the size of a change to x
squared caused by some change to X and
then we're dividing out by DT likewise
the rate at which Y of T squared is
changing is 2 times y of T times the
derivative of Y now evidently this whole
expression must be zero and that's an
equivalent way of saying that x squared
plus y squared must not change while the
ladder moves at the very start time T
equals 0 the height Y of T is 4 meters
and that distance X of T is 3 meters and
since the top of the ladder is dropping
at a rate of 1 meter per second that
derivative dy DT is negative 1
per second now this gives us enough
information to isolate the derivative
dx/dt and when you work it out it comes
out to be 4/3 meters per second the
reason I bring up this latter problem is
that I want you to compare it to the
problem of finding the slope of a
tangent line to the circle in both cases
we had the equation x squared plus y
squared equals 5 squared and in both
cases we ended up taking the derivative
of each side of this expression but for
the latter question these expressions
were functions of time so taking the
derivative has a clear meaning it's the
rate at which the expression changes as
time changes but what makes the circle
situation strange is that rather than
saying that a small amount of time DT
has passed which causes X and Y to
change the derivative just has these
tiny nudges DX and dy just floating free
not tied to some other common variable
like time let me show you a nice way to
think about this let's give this
expression x squared plus y squared a
name maybe s s is essentially a function
of two variables it takes every point XY
on the plane and associates it with a
number four points on the circle that
number happens to be 25 if you stepped
off the circle away from the center that
value would be bigger for other points
XY closer to the origin that value would
be smaller now what it means to take a
derivative of this expression a
derivative of s is to consider a tiny
change to both of these variables some
tiny change DX to X and some tiny change
D Y to Y and not necessarily one that
keeps you on the circle by the way it's
just any tiny step in any direction of
the XY plane and from there you ask how
much does the value of s change and that
difference the difference in the value
of s before the nudge and after the
nudge is what I'm writing as D s for
example in this picture we're starting
off at a point where x equals 3 and
where y equals 4 and let's just say that
that step I drew has DX at negative zero
point zero
- and dy at negative 0.01 then the
decrease in s the amount that x squared
plus y squared changes over that step
would be about two times three times
negative 0.02 plus two times 4 times
negative 0.01 that's what this
derivative expression 2x DX plus 2y dy
actually means it's a recipe for telling
you how much the value x squared plus y
squared changes as determined by the
point XY where you start and the tiny
step DX dy that you take and as with all
things derivative this is only an
approximation but it's one that gets
truer and truer for smaller and smaller
choices of DX and dy the key point here
is that when you restrict yourself to
steps along the circle you're
essentially saying you want to ensure
that this value of s doesn't change it
starts at a value of 25 and you want to
keep it at a value of 25 that is DS
should be 0 so setting the expression 2x
DX plus 2y dy equal to 0 is the
condition under which one of these tiny
steps actually stays on the circle again
this is only an approximation speaking
more precisely that condition is what
keeps you on the tangent line of the
circle not the circle itself but for
tiny enough steps those are essentially
the same thing of course there's nothing
special about the expression x squared
plus y squared equals 5 squared it's
always nice to think through more
examples so let's consider this
expression sine of x times y squared
equals x this corresponds to a whole
bunch of u-shaped curves on the plane
and those curves remember represent all
of the points XY where the value of sine
of x times y squared happens to equal
the value of X
now imagine taking some tiny step with
components dxdy and not necessarily one
that keeps you on the curve taking the
derivative of each side of this equation
is going to tell us how much the value
of that side changes during the step on
the left side the product rule that we
talked through last video tells us that
this should be lefty right plus right D
left that is sine of X times the change
to y squared which is to Y times dy plus
y squared times the change to sine of X
which is cosine of x times DX the right
side is simply X so the size of a change
to that value is exactly DX right now
setting these two sides equal to each
other is a way of saying whatever your
tiny step with coordinates DX and dy is
if it's going to keep us on the curve
the values of both the left-hand side
and the right-hand side must change by
the same amount that's the only way that
this top equation can remain true from
there depending on what problem you're
trying to solve
you have something to work with
algebraically and maybe the most common
goal is to try to figure out what dy
divided by DX is
as a final example here I want to show
you how you can actually use this
technique of implicit differentiation to
figure out new derivative formulas I've
mentioned that the derivative of e to
the X is itself but what about the
derivative of its inverse function the
natural log of X well the graph of the
natural log of X can be thought of as an
implicit curve it's all of the points XY
on the plane where Y happens to equal Ln
of X it just happens to be the case that
the X's and the Y's of this equation
aren't as intermingled as they were in
our other examples the slope of this
graph dy / DX should be the derivative
of Ln of X right well to find that first
rearrange this equation y equals Ln of X
to be e to the y equals x this is
exactly what the natural log of X means
it's saying e to the what equals X since
we know the derivative of e to the Y we
can take the derivative of both sides
here effectively asking how a tiny step
with components DX dy changes the value
of each one of these sides to ensure
that a step stays on the curve the
change to this left side of the equation
which is e to the Y times dy must equal
the change to the right side which in
this case is just DX rearranging that
means that dy / DX the slope of our
graph equals one divided by e to the Y
and when we're on the curve e to the Y
is by definition the same thing as X so
evidently this slope is 1 divided by X
and of course an expression for the
slope of a graph of a function written
in terms of X like this is the
derivative of that function so evidently
the derivative of Ln of X is 1 / X
you
by the way all of this is a little sneak
peek into multivariable calculus where
you consider functions that have
multiple inputs and how they change as
you tweak those multiple inputs the key
as always is to have a clear image in
your head of what tiny nudges are at
play and how exactly they depend on each
other next up I'm going to be talking
about limits and how they're used to
formalize the idea of a derivative
[Music]
you